so 365 days this day is out and i don't
know how they were supposed to edit this
because the movie's dirtier than amber
hood's bed sheets the film makes the
first one look oscar worthy and for as
sh as it is i can't get enough of it
i'll be honest i cannot get enough of
this stuff everyone who's been asking
why we haven't had the time to cover
better call saul is about to have a
meltdown because we're lubing up and
going in deep on this netflix classic
that's about to win all those
subscribers back yeah it's gonna cost
you so sit back grab a box of tissues no
not for that and follow us as we break
down the movie and it's ending if you
enjoy the video then please hit it till
you quit it on the thumbs up button and
make sure you subscribe like it's a copy
of reader's wives without the way thank
you for clicking this now let's get into
the movie so if you don't recall because
the writers didn't the first movie ended
with laura heading into a tunnel just as
a mafia arrival of massimo was about to
attack she was pregnant heading back
from trying on dresses as the movie
closed out with it seeming like she was
about to either be killed or kidnapped
what was the outcome was laura taken was
she murdered will massimo head out on a
rip-roaring rampage of revenge and
shagging well no not really as the movie
glosses over that like the dialogue
scenes and we get some simple lip
service paid to it earlier on in the
film this movie is of course based on
the book series of the same name and
this loosely follows the second one in
that with massimo's twin brother coming
onto the scene the second book is
essentially a retread of the first one
but this day i can't believe i'm saying
this tells a better story sure it's like
porn but the acting isn't as good and
there's an over-reliance on sex scenes
but it's actually better somehow now
there is a polish language and polisher
turd put in there but our brain is
pretty wrecked by this whole film this
brings a whole new meaning to tiger
woods in your pants and you'll be
turning yourself into a dessert by the
end of it as you desert your morals by
watching it i have to blame this all out
cause
damn me now the movie starts off with
laura having her pasty smashed more than
someone who angered a greg's worker but
she reveals she sadly lost the baby her
mate olga finds laura massimo
consummating before the wedding night
and says it's bad luck to destroy your
bride's box before the big day which
yeah it goes downhill for them from here
on out the lack of any continuation of
the storyline from the first movie is
justified as massimo didn't know she was
pregnant and they don't want to start a
war we then go to the wedding day and
hear the song ave maria and deep down i
hope that the riddler was watching them
about to start a killing spree now if
you thought they weren't gonna go all
out for the wedding night in this barely
disguised softcore porno then i have a
non-fungible token to sell you of course
i can't show what laura is doing so
here's some footage of an innuendo well
she gets it in her endo we get a montage
of sex as laura spreads it on the green
for an easy shot down the fairway for a
hole in one and massimo's friend hooks
up with laura's buddy olga because
well i guess the writers thought there
wasn't enough hanky-panky i actually
watched the movie at 1.5 speed and it
looked like an x-rated benny hill but
with more attractive people
debatable now after the honeymoon
massimo is back to his typical ways and
he controls laura by sending her away
with olga she is simply a wife basically
just an object and nothing more kind of
didn't know what she expected as he
spent years looking for her and ended up
kidnapping her sure he was handsome but
yeah there were some major red flags now
after being injected by dominico olga
has a heart-to-heart with laura and
laura decides to explain her demands to
live a proper life as opposed to being
his prisoner it's absolutely wild that
she's like yeah we start off with me
being kidnapped but i fell in love and
now she draws the line and not being
able to do what she wants it's also at
this point she meets nacho the dark and
mysterious gardener with sick tats who
turns up in a justin timberlake 2 000
spit in a line which is no doubt the
worst of the movie laura says you have a
nice cap which i'm sure is as the kids
say no cap this begins the start of the
two identity mix-ups for the movie as
nacho is in reality the son of a rival
crime boss he reveals himself later and
honestly i think the guy had been taking
acting lessons from johnny's sins ask
your man about him ladies i know this is
what you guys find enticing but us men
we love the master of disguise
he was masquerading as a gardener for
most of the film but he still found some
time to lay some seed and spend time in
laura's bush when he abandoned the cover
story his father tasked him with
manipulating laura so that he could
install massimo's as of yet unmentioned
twin brother as the head of his gang
judah massimo expanding his empire
aggressively she confesses how unhappy
she is with just being a wife marking
her ready for his deception plans but
not before we see one of the most
graphic sex scenes i think i've ever
seen it's 50 shades of brown and the
pillow talk reveals how massimo has a
brother and how mario from the first
movie has retired and gone back to his
own planet
turns out that he and his brother had
fallen out years prior and though evil
twin plots became cliched in the 70s
here we are now we catch a glimpse of
him as he starts his part of the rival
crime boss's plan and he pretends to be
massimo coincidentally after an argument
she catches what we think is massimo
absolutely railing anna rotten but it
was all a plan by adriano we learn he is
better that his brother was born a few
minutes before him meaning that he's
always looked over and has spent the
years seeking revenge which i can't
believe i said earlier in the video that
this story was better but moving on not
learning from the first movie laura then
decides to head off and live with the
gardener she met for five minutes she
arrives at his luxurious beach home not
questioning how he can afford this on a
gardener's wage but until she's been
there for a couple of days
sorry i go through that again
she arrives at his luxurious beach home
not question
[Laughter]
as she arrives at his luxurious beach
home not questioning how he can afford
this una god no age until she's been
there for a few days laura ends up
spending more time living the life of
luxury and she even got to wear the cap
she admired when she first met nacho
massimo and nacho are of course very
similar fiercely loyal and infatuated
with laura hey nacho that's not your
wife eh haven't that now massimo deduces
his ex anna is involved and he leaves
his fancy lobs to dinner i like how his
wife is missing and he's like all right
i'm going to head out
now in one of the worst scenes in the
movie massimo's brother is told laura
isn't where they thought and he kills a
henchman you know to show how different
the brothers are they never actually
properly introduce him before the end of
the movie so you just think massimo has
gone unhinged and that we're watching
some episode of moon night where
everyone is really poo night nacho and
laura get even closer and she actually
ends up falling for him in the creepiest
scene of the movie he kisses her when
she's asleep and he goes downtown on her
box before massimo's henchman arrives to
bring laura back he's taken out by nacho
who had to be staring at the window to
catch him well i mean you could have
killed him if you wanted clearly though
the scriptwriters had enough of the
movie and wanted to chip off to the pub
as they start to wrap things up at this
point nacho heads to visit his father as
the movie cuts to a shot of his dad that
feels overly dramatic
yes i'm saying that about this moment
and not the rest of the movie which is
also overly dramatic now he reveals two
years as laura's like oh bloody hell not
again and she accidentally fell for a
mafioso once more but he does care for
her she's taken to see his father and
everything is laid bare in front of
massimo he realizes he's been cooked but
i wonder if laura will just call it an
entanglement as massimo prepares to go
full will smith you never go full will
smith now he is implored to slow down
his criminal expansion and if he doesn't
his twin brother will replace him as the
head of the family however adriana has
kidnapped her from nacho's father and
the brother reveals himself to her with
nacho and massimo in one almighty
dramatic showdown this is some jacob and
edward teaming up to save bella but
laura is shot after wriggling free from
adriano leading anna to be shot as well
and then the evil twin i don't know why
this was filmed in ultra mega slow
motion either because the movie was
already long enough however laura did
run towards massimo indicating she cared
for him more causing nacho to walk away
from them it is ambiguous as to if she
survives or not but no doubt he will
bring her back because without her
there's not much of a story netflix have
already confirmed the third film is in
the works and that laura will indeed be
returning the third book synopsis has
also been released and it does state
that she'll be back as a main focus of
the storyline it states as the wife of
don massimo one of the most dangerous
mafia bosses in sicily laura's life is a
roller coaster which you can say that
again she's often at risk the potential
target of massimo's unscrupulous enemies
who will stop at nothing to destroy the
powerful man and when laura is seriously
injured in an attack pregnant and
fighting to survive massimo faces the
toughest decision of his life what will
his life be without laura will he be
able to raise their child alone what
will the fate of the family be and whose
365 days may come to a close so it does
seem like the baby that was thrown out
with the bathwater plotline could
possibly return and that they might have
to put a stop to the sex and focus on
that potentially massimo will try to
protect laura and take her away from
this life as you know she's gonna be in
a lot of danger maybe he'll even have a
moment of self-reflection where he
realizes that she's a prisoner instead
of a wife and he'll finally let her go
overall there's lots of things to look
forward to i guess and i'd love to hear
your thoughts on the movie below i'm not
even going to score it because netflix
will probably cut me off from press
screeners but
three out of ten
three out of ten so yeah not going to
give it a score but let me know yours
below we are in a competition right now
and giving away three copies of
spider-man now a home on the 15th of
april and all you have to do to be on
the chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the episode
if you want something else to watch
that's actually good then there's a
video on screen right now so definitely
go head over there right after this i've
had a lot of fun with this one i hope
you have two and cheers for sitting with
me take care peace